they put me down
they asked me to do squat
for
other counters hours
and once that i felt shuffle
they bit me
being beaten
facing uncertain future
i don't even know whether that i would
die
at that place
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
can you explain why did you go to china
in august of 2019
well that time i need to join a business
conference that time in shenzhen i
understand that much me
must be a bit tricky because that
exactly the time
what happens the protest happens in hong
kong
and it is a bit dangerous to me then
i've been stopped and i put back to the
course today
they gave me no reason
then they said oh it's because it's too
late now i need to deliver you back to
shenzhen because
we we have something to ask you or
something
and i felt a bit
worried what happened but
my
instincts and my intuition
told me that is about politics of course
so i understand is not simple
and
they keep asking me to
access my phone so that's why they
deliver me back to shenzhen
and they hand me over to a bunch of
principles officers
they showed no batches
and they treat me very very very rudely
they say shut up
don't ask the reason
you will know
then they put me into the course they
put me into the
cell
and they put me on the tiger chair tiger
chairs is the chair
but
they could buckle me up i can't move
then
i've been handcuffed
and attached to the chair
and my legs would be also shackled
and attached attach the chair so i can't
move
and they ask three type of questions
mainly
what do you think about hong kong
and then they start to narrow down to
get more specific answers
and they ask
why you want to
attend the protest
and what job you do you're doing and
what's role of the uk behind the protest
and who and who you know
enjoy the protest
there's something like that and
surrounding and surrounding i feel very
intimidating because
i understand that even one message
on my whatsapp
it could be an evidence for them to do
political charges
when i be put into the detention center
that is civilian police nothing to do
with the state security
so the state security police didn't need
to get into the detention center ask me
out
every time for interrogation because
that is about so-called secret
so when i've been asked out for
interrogation
i've been blindfolded i've been hooted
i've been shackled i've been handcuffed
and dropped me on the unknown car
drove me into the unknown place
and i felt that it's
very very dead silent
and i heard
the sounds of moving furniture
and i understand that is
some tool for torture
because i understand that as the whole
process abnormal and unusual
and certainly that state put me
into a very very uncomfortable and
comfortable position they hung me up
for kindness hour that i can't remember
and they also sometimes i fell
shuffle because that is too painful
that's without any evidence because they
held me up
the pains it cannot be feasible
and they told me they put me down
they asked me to do squat
for
either counters hours
and once that i felt shuffle
they bit me
using a non weapon
because i can't see anything i still
being hooted
it's very very hard to breathe because
that is not for you to breathe actually
so i sweat a lot hard to breathe
being beaten
facing uncertain future
then they said
every time
if you wanna speak
you need to say
report my master in mandarin
i wanted to let you know who is your
master
not
britain
not in english
in manchester madness
china
and
is so inhumane because i felt being
dehumanized
and
that time
i've been bitten
and sometimes too ill i felt too ill
they asked me to stand still
i can't move anything i can't move at
all
and they try to
deprive my sleep
for other
of hours
and every time when i've been put back
to the detention center
lots of bruises on my legs i can't even
move
and i put into the detention center and
afterwards then i put into the personal
cell i'll be put into this electric
confinement because the state security
police
they don't want to
to let me to
tell what situation i am to others
inmates
and i felt loneliness
so i tried q time
that i sent myself
and i prayed myself
and that's how things could maintain my
mentality
and that's the only way i could
be rational
otherwise and i even thought that i
might
commit suicide they need to get more
information to charge me politically
so
they claim well simon i understand that
sometime you
went for the trip when shenzhen went to
massachusetts
tell me whether that useless prostitutes
and i understand it hints because if i
don't confess that
i would be politically charged
immediately
and what i will be treated would be
criminal
detention
they try to persuade me
to confess
a light to charge
so i had no choice i said yes i confess
and that's what becoming now
probationed and the state media said i
said as a prostitute
and this kind of thing's becoming the
social stigma upon me
for the rest of my life even after
i've been let out
and that has three times a confession
videotape
the one is i betray my motherland
that is for the preparedness that they
charge me politically in the future
so now that's why i've been put on the
quantities by the national security
police in hong kong
the second one that i admit
i confess i said as a prostitute
and the third types of confession video
types
is
they
they treat me very well
they ask me and have to say there's no
torture
and that's they they protect my legal
rights to let me assess my lawyers and
family
but i rejected
how long have chinese authorities
detained you for
they did take me for
15 days
and i was very lucky
because
i thought i would be imprisoned for
decades
out of those 15 days which moment you
think was the worst
most worst
of course as it went the moment that
i've been tortured
especially the first day
because after few days that they keep
torturing me
i literally get used to it but first
it's still very very short that they
could do that on me
so why do you think the chinese
authorities let you go
that time my family members and my
girlfriend
report my missing
in hong kong
so that time
it becomes a global news headline
and i think that is one of the reasons
actually could help me
because when i look back
when the week that they started to stop
the torture
is exactly when
the new standard media report my missing
case globally
they felt pressure
i think that time
i try my best to be cooperative why i
need to rescue my life
i don't want to betray to my my friends
my protesters that i know
and i try best to deny
deny the charges they claim that
i work for the uk government
to stigmatize the uk government to prove
the uk government
is behind the scenes for the protest
that is what the beijing wanted to their
own propaganda they said that as a
foreign power and manipulation
they could trigger the nationalism
blightful blight nationalism with the
people stick with the regime stick with
the government
that's what they wanted me to play that
role
but i deny
that almost immediately when i finished
the reports to the british council what
happened to them
what happened to me as well
then i left
and i didn't
even tell to my family members to say i
never have a good comeback no
it just pretend
as usual
i just try to spend the last few days
with my family members i understand that
maybe the last few days for the rest of
my life to be with them
but i can't speak it out because
they're too old to take that
they're too old to understand the
complexity
of the matter
i have a last dinner with them
and suddenly i took the flight to taiwan
and i say goodbye
and that's it and i cut tight with my
family
i felt that's a about the time i need to
talk with the bbc
that is about the time that
i blotten me i publicly broke the
promise with the state security police
in maine in china
to say look
i speak out
i spoke out
then
next date
my confession videotapes have been
broadcasted
by the state media
from beijing in the uk
around the world
so for now i'm an activist full-time
activist because i'm very very hard to
go back to normality
and that's why now i set up an ngo
i set up a non-profit organization i try
to solidify hong kong in the uk named
hong kong as in britain on august 2020
i have been reportedly on the want list
by the hong kong national security
police
so i understand that they keep hunting
me down
and even it's not safe even the uk i
think that is not one of
because the claim the state security law
from hong kong could operate globally
regardless
what kind of nationalities you're
holding
so
that is almost always the risk to me
from
the very beginning
why they tried to take me
and until now becoming a frontline
advocate for democracy
put on the want list
because what
my advocacy
because just simply because i speak out
the truth
[Music]
on the day arrest me in front my five
years old child
my heart is to speed with
and i know that is if i arrested and
sent back to north korea
i just execute or press